All right guys, so this is gonna be the last example for the holy grail strategy and this is gonna be a unique strategy
Sorry example, right?
Instead of going from external liquidity to internal we're gonna go from internal to external
And I thought that it would be best to show you one example as well
Although I don't use this method, but it can work for you as well
I mean it does work, but I don't like it for some reason. I don't know what's the reason, but yeah
So for this method for this thing to be like very accurate you have to look at the auto flow
So are we bearish so you want to look at the bearish for valley gaps, right?
So over here, but we have on the four hour time frame
So on for this example, we're gonna go from four hour to five or fifteen minutes to one minute, okay?
So this is the fair valley gap
Right and this is practically our take profit level, right?
It could also be this here because that is the extended liquidity here
So now let's go to the 15-minute time frame and look for a shift in the market structure
And that happens right there with this structure break, right? So now what we are looking for
So you could have simply taken your entry from this fair valley gap, but as you can see that price came here
There was not enough
Range for us to be going to the one minute time frame and look for consolidation here, right?
So what we can do is firstly you could have used the
The strategy by itself, you know taking the entry using two time frames, but
Now that we have gone way below we can look for a continuation purchase, right?
So over here, but you can see is we had this purge here, so let's go and
Study what happened here because I want to be crystal clear with you guys
There is no consolidation here. Do you see the consolidation? I do not look at this
This is the starting point, right? We're going up low low low low low low low high sorry high high low high low high low high low
That this is like no consolidation here, so we do not take the trade here. Let's go to the 15-minute time frame once again
I'm showing you the different variations of each strategy because it's not gonna be like
You know like a birter like it's you will not get the same price action like before okay
It's gonna be different every time, but you have to scout out these setups. So over here
We also have a continuation purge, but look at this move guys
This is not a purge. This is a breakout
Okay, and even if we like let's say have this level right because this is the move
But there's no consolidation here. Let's go here once again
There's no consolidation here. So we are still not interested in taking that trade. So let's go to the 15 minutes once again
And now at 10 45 right we have a purge
Now this is the move that took out this so now we have to scout out for consolidation
Here and right away. What do you see? We have this beautiful consolidation right there?
Do you understand what I'm trying to teach here you have to look for these things, okay?
Consolidation phase here accumulation phase one accumulation phase two three and even four here
So now we take out this liquidity, right? We have a shift in the market structure
We're gonna take our entry from the breaker block
Because our stops gonna be going that they they're like anyways, right
That's gonna be our entry stop right above the highs
Right there and looking to target these levels also look at this thing
We have a fake bullish autoflow. So when you have this every single fairway gap is respected
If everybody got respected fairway gap respected fairway gap respected there's fairly gap as well
That is respected and this one is respected as well
But then this is all build up of liquidity, right? So now let's see how this plays out
Beautiful right to the beautiful delivery, right now if you waited for let's say, okay
Here's why did I take my entry from this breaker block?
Right because we have a fairly gap inside this breaker block
We have this really gap inside this breaker block, right? We have an auto block inside this breaker block, right?
So wouldn't it be wise?
To take a trade from the breaker breaker instead of waiting for price to come here because only one minute
Especially price is very very like intense, okay?
It's very strong. So it may not hit your fairly gap on one minute. So
Utilize the breaker look at the look at these things, okay?
If you take your entry from a breaker
It's your stop gonna be the same almost the same if you took your entry from this fairly gap or this auto block
If yes, go for it
If you don't want to miss your trade go for the like the closest fairly gap, right?
This could be this but all this put your stop here
and
I think guys that is it for this lecture. I want you guys to back test
I try my best to show you the different variations, right in each example
So you can better understand this whole system, okay?
We had this we didn't have consolidation here, but then look at this
Let's see the difference between here and here boom boom boom boom boom boom
But here, but do we have we have nothing price?
consecutive green candles pull back green candles pull back green candles pull back
So yeah, I think guys that is it
I'm gonna do one or two more lectures about let's say how to pause your profile and a one bonus video
All right, and then the course update will end if we have understood everything that I've taught right now
Congratulations, you are about to become an independent trader, okay?
When you have like the bias you can use my every single strategy even the basics ones right by
Using like in external and internal for this example
I showed you internal and external that can work as well
But you need to know the auto flow if you have the correct auto flow that is absolutely beautiful
All right, I'm gonna end the video here. See you guys in the next one